and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn Ryan
Nicodemus is in Scotland today but don't
worry I found some other person with a
very strong jaw line to fill in for him
why thank you Jane ashes in the studio
today we're gonna talk about artistry
we're gonna talk about resourceful Ness
we're gonna talk about originality we're
gonna talk about craft and so we have a
craftsman here today on my favorite
musicians Jay Nash you can find his
music at Jay Nash calm now Jay you uh
you've been writing about minimalism
before I even started writing about
minimalism I was uh
I wondered if that's how I ended up here
is just the the title of a record yeah
is that what got is that what got me in
this room I think you know so the things
we think we need right things you think
you think oh yes yeah for judgmental
yeah no I think you know and so so that
that line is from I think the first song
on that record right is we talkin liar
yes and it's really about forsaking the
people that we love to get a bunch of
stuff that is useless more or less yeah
it is more being hyper focused on on
some end goal and sort of sacrificing
the here and now for this it could be a
thing it could be it could be an entity
it could be a place that you want to get
to it could be you know a life goal but
they I guess the end point of that
particular line in the song is that
you're just sort of pissing away the
right now which is really you know if
you get down into it with whether it's
philosophy or religion really this
moment this time this point this instant
is is everything right right at the same
time feel like we're terrified of the
present moment we're terrified of of
boredom we're too and so we pacify
ourselves quite often with those things
and now it can be physical things and I
think that's the sort of literal
interpretation to get the things you
think you need yeah but those other
thing there are other things that we
pacify ourselves with and and now it's
it's it's happening more than every I've
got this glowing screen in my pocket
the provide a Juris you bright not very
dangerous and so I think when you wrote
that you probably weren't thinking about
Instagram because it didn't exist yet
but did not know I think I still had a
flip phone and and I didn't also set out
to you know that record is called the
things you think you need but you know I
didn't set out to write a record about
living a minimalist lifestyle by any
means really that was about the sort of
the futile gestures that that many of us
you know I was a part of this big Los
Angeles music scene you know as I was in
a relationship that was really
everything but I didn't fully see it you
know for a minute there and the record
at large is about the concept it's less
about the material things but you can
apply it to the material things for sure
because plenty of people do get
completely lost in the pursuit of
creature comforts
absolutely the average American
household has 300,000 items in it and
and you know when you look at that I I
think quite often middle made me sweat a
little bit
all right I was thinking about my own
house is like can we oh no oh it's
toolshed yeah you live in Vermont and
see we were talking about this before we
started recording you need a lot of your
kids need about 17 different pairs of
shoes just to survive the winters you
need a lot of shoes a lot of tools a lot
of things to go outside and play and
survive the winter with it is that it is
a challenge all right Jay we've got a
bunch of questions here today that I
think will aid our conversation our
first question is from Ellen in Boulder
Colorado I have been cutting
our technology than minimizing that how
do you cope with the boredom of no
longer having that pacifier of you
constant need to take out your phone and
having this free time that you may have
opened up now that you're no longer
using things like social media and
Netflix all the time how do you cope
with that more than simply just filling
the void with another hobby and how do
you get used to that so Jay I don't know
if you found this but you've been making
music for a while mm-hmm still making
music I am yes still making some
beautiful music by the way and I think
we are also forced to be our own sort of
self promoters in this time as well and
social media is a way to do that but
it's also a way that to distract
ourselves and you some people use social
media to create and that is their medium
they're their choice Yeah right
some people are particularly great at it
absolutely some people are great at
making you know conventional forms of
art whether it's writing and or making
music or films but they're also just
extremely def done on social media it's
cool do you find it be do you find that
technology is a distraction for you now
that does it keep you from from or has
it ever kept you from producing anything
meaningful well I think that there
certainly have been times you know where
I would lean on it and say if I'm
sitting in a tour van for I got a six
hour drive and you know you can only
look at you looking at the window for so
long and read a book for a minute and
it's easy to go to the to the feed you
know to sort of as she said pacify your
mind but I've always been a little bit
dubious of it you know since the
beginning I used to make all my record
when I live in Los Angeles up until 2010
I guess is when I started making records
with computers again because the the
technology got to be at a point where
the sound was comparable to what you
could get from a tape machine but prior
to that all my records were made without
a screening from me I always felt like
the screen
took me out of it I don't know if it's a
if there's a physiological biological
explanation for what happens when you're
staring at those frequencies of lights
but like to me it would turn off a lot
of the creative thought so I was always
kind of very careful about you know
staring at a screen that's what got me
into music in the first place you know I
studied engineering at the University of
Vermont and the thing I hated most about
the engineering program was just sitting
in a room staring at a screen and and
you know not getting explanations on the
derivations of things but here's the
protocol what you need to tell the
computer to get the right results for
you know a whole series of variables I
mean I played music but obviously before
that engineering was a bit of a
distraction but that was my biggest
complaint about engineering I just want
to sit there with a drool coming on
mouth staring at a screen I didn't like
I didn't like the feeling of the way
things shut down inside of my inside of
my mind that said technology has
progressed and and it's easy to lean on
these things and use technology as tools
both to create the art that were we're
trying to express ourselves with and to
draw attention to it so I would say to
it was Ellen right yeah there's it's a
great big world you know it's it might
there's probably going to be a period of
learning curve if she's deliberately
shutting off her her phone and and
dealing without it but I mean there's a
lot of great books out there and if you
like to rediscover the joy of reading a
book or to rediscover the joy of
listening to music undistracted in you
know in sort of a pristine setting or
just look at the top of a tree you know
look at the top of a tree against the
the backdrop of the sky and you're
probably gonna feel something give
yourself a second you know if you don't
feel in the first five seconds give
yourself a few more seconds take a deep
breath and think about what a miracle it
is that like that's there and you're
seeing it yeah I feel like you're going
deeper in those instances like you're
guaranteed to get some very fleeting
ephemeral burst of dopamine if you go to
Instagram and someone liked this
yeah but but that's the that is it's a
media but it's not deep it's not deep
the same way that like going out and
spending some time in nature or just
sitting with your boredom for a while
and yeah even if you go back to the
Stoics you look at like Seneca or
epictetus I you look at yes I think sit
with Seneca who said you'll get rid of
your books and go and explore the world
and now like for us it'll add to the
book yes I please that but for them
books were their social media in a way
that people were it was a distraction
for me people it was a distraction from
real life right right and so so I think
we sometimes we accidentally just bring
new pacifiers I don't know for me it's
it's it's podcast like I all listen to
too many podcast and I'm like okay I
need to take a day without any earbuds
and yeah in my ears
yeah or if I do have your buds in my
ears let me rediscover this thing called
music because man it's really good I was
listening I can make you feel things
yeah I was listened to your new song
this morning keepers of the time yeah
and on the I was coming into work all
right here into the to the studio and I
was listening to that I'm Lee wins last
time it's probably been two weeks since
I've deliberately sat down and listened
to some music
because podcasts have have been over
podcasts are doing the same thing to me
I have to admit you know especially
these long-form podcasts where you get
to know somebody that you didn't know
before right now they get to be a fly on
the wall yeah it's fun well if I were to
rephrase Ellen's question I would
basically say she's saying how do i best
use my free time to explore new passions
and that might be a deeper conversation
well yeah I agree but also like
recognizing a few things one is this is
some free time I don't have to fill it
immediately if only I had free time
maybe I mean well actually that's a
better question that so you don't have a
lot of free time because you have a
family and you have a lot of snow
removal I mean it's it's it's we're
recording this in July and you're still
removing snow and in Vermont I'm sure
the snow is finally melted yeah now
we're just getting ready for the snow to
fall again we're trying to fix all the
things that need to get fixed before it
starts
because he's gonna come so you don't
have a ton of free time but you still
find time to create yeah well that is my
job you know so that is uh you know I
carve out time as a priority you know it
heard for some people you know you get
up you take a shower you have your
breakfast you go to work so you know for
me we've identified in our household
that if I don't make stuff it's gonna
make things you know a little bit less
comfortable for the family and there's
you know there's the promotion of stuff
and there's occasionally I do work as a
composer I do work as a producer but
really it all comes from songs
it all comes from sort of mining the
ether for something that hasn't been
said before something that I haven't
said before finding the new perspective
on things and the only way to get there
is to carve out that takes time you know
there's no magic bullet for for a great
I'd find a great idea you have to kind
of keep yourself open to it might come
to you when you're you know in line to
order you know your your favorite Thai
food in a busy restaurant or but then
you still it may come to time I even so
you got to get that you got to log the
idea at save it for later but then you
got to set the time aside so you know
after you've had your breakfast and
taking the kids to school then you sit
down in the studio and you know the the
phone is faced down the screen is off
you're looking out the window stare at
the top of the tree and just see what's
there
you know and some days it may be nothing
but you got to you got to make the time
I'm working on a new book right now Ryan
and I are called love people use things
and great title thank you
sort of how we end every every podcast
episode it started when we were on tour
in 2014 which you were part of thank you
you know part of that and we just
started ending our events well I
remember that I remember that and saying
we had a conversation I think it Capote
way afterwards and and so we're working
on this book and I find that yeah I get
these ideas and I logged them but I have
to spend four hours a day pretty
every day writing because otherwise the
ideas are just ideas and they're sitting
there in a file and that file is not
going to really be meaningful for anyone
unless I can mine it and and and create
it's weird as a writer and or as a
musician you find that like you not only
have to like chisel out the sculpture
but you also have to create the rock up
through which the sculpture is is allow
in a way well that's a great concept
about the for our role you know work for
four hours a day you know you really
have four hours to beat your sort of
optimal creative output and some days
those four hours it can be extremely
prolific in other days not so much it's
possible but you know to get back to
Ellen's question I think that it's a
matter of identifying where your
priorities in your life are you know are
you fulfilling all of are you checking
all the boxes you know and if you're not
where you want to be in some of those
categories you know make the conscious
decision to take the 30 minutes that you
would have spent you know scrolling
through a feed and taking some direct
action towards achieving you know that
goal or that you know fulfilling what is
left unfulfilled I think that I think
this day and age we don't have it we're
so inundated with information with
images with ideas all the time that we
don't have enough space to really know
where we stand you know in terms of you
know sort of achieving what we set out
to achieve in our lives and and
fulfilling our really are fulfilling our
responsibilities in our relationships
whether it's family or personal or you
know friend or any so you know that take
take the time to enjoy the space yeah
enjoy it we hear this thing I don't know
how applies to you but we hear this this
there's a sort of aphorism of writers
don't like writing they like having
written because you like having the
album done or whatever yeah me I'm the
exact opposite yeah I I'm never
completely satisfied and I'm sure you
with music it's even more complex
because you're like oh yeah I could have
done this different or whatever but like
I actually enjoyed the process more than
the product and it takes a while to get
there yeah but when you can really enjoy
the process when when there's this sort
of focus time you could call flow state
whatever you want to call it and there's
nothing more rewarding when when the
song is going just right or I want to
come together there's nothing more
exciting now in in as soon as you know
you have a seed I guess songwriting is a
little bit different than an essay
writing or you know book writing yeah I
have limited experience as as a writer
of non-musical things but occasionally I
do it occasionally I'll you know kind of
just go down the rabbit hole on
something but it is a different thing
you know it's it is I don't want to
sound pretentious and I probably will
and I apologize but writing music trying
to get to the place of whatever you want
to call it divine inspiration and it's
different when you have an assignment
sometimes you have an assignment
sometimes you're you're you're working
out an arrangement for an existing song
that's fun but it's a little bit more
mechanical or if you're the you know if
I'm composing music for picture for film
or for like a commercial or something
like that it's like then I have an
assignment I have boundaries right now
I'm trying to find the right thing I
have some source of information but when
there's just the impulse usually songs
are not convenient you know you don't
necessarily say oh I want to write a
song about that you've already by the
time you're writing the song it's it's
all it's happening because it had to
happen because you've felt some emotion
that you weren't able to process
internally without some discomfort and
and so did it manifests itself as a song
or it's you know some that I think that
and you've probably heard other
songwriters say this writing songs about
that expressed joy
effectively in sort of a non cloying way
is is like one of the most difficult
things to do you know because like how
many different ways are there to say you
know like oh it's a beautiful day you
know why there are so many variations of
sad songs because it's there seems to be
a bunch of different ways to talk about
agony or suffering or or pain and
they're seen at the same time it brings
us together in a way because everyone
has some you know underlying discomfort
you know there's a lot of things that
are uncomfortable about you know in
relation to the human experience yeah
you know that's it's it's a miracle and
a tragedy at the same time and the way
we tend to handle you know tragedy or
despair is isolation and so the thing
about a sad song is that it destroys the
barriers of isolation and and if you're
feeling it and you hear a song that kind
of says the same thing all the sudden
you're not alone in the universe you
know it's a rare beautiful thing and I
don't know I don't know what else there
is in this world that does the same
thing you know I read sad books and I'm
honest sad you know like I just went
down the and what I like a little
Steinbeck kick of reading is his short
works and they're so engrossing you get
so deep in there you just like well it's
beautiful but but yeah it's it's tough
you know doesn't it doesn't have the
same thing you know a lot of my favorite
songs are sad and I listen to him but
the song ends I'm full of joy you know
like what a beautiful thing that this
happened you know well Ellen I'm gonna
send you a copy of our book our first
book minimalism live a meaningful life
there's a whole chapter in there about
passion and I think that you Jay hit a
nail on the head he talked about
priorities I would just say priority
it's a weird it's a weird word because
well up until the 20th century do you
know that we didn't have a plural for
the word priority because it literally
means the etymology of the word it may
the first thing oh yeah okay and and so
we're now you know the United Nations
release their list of 163 priorities
Gregg McEwen talks about this and I mean
when you think about that you step back
here like you have a hundred and
sixty-three first things it's like well
wait a minute yeah you don't actually
have any first thing at that point right
and so I think they're reading back to
the point about we're at this day and
age were all inundated right right and
and trying to filter out a lot of that
noise so you can figure out what's the
priority right now and for you it could
be the mornings where you're you're
creating for that three or four hours in
the evenings your priority and family
you know in and quite often our
priorities are actually what we do with
our time we might say my priorities are
XY and Z but if I'm spending all my time
just scrolling Instagram and checking
email and attending useless meetings and
those are my real priorities so Alan if
you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of minimalism live a
meaningful life or if you want the book
book or the e-book podcast Sean will
send you one of those as well
our next question is from Matt in
Columbus we paid off all of our debts
including over twenty five thousand and
student loans we have reduced our cost
of living to the point where we are now
living on less than 50% of our income
which has allowed us to travel to places
like Machu Picchu and pay down a
significant amount of our mortgage we
have chosen to not have children we're
not planning on changing our lifestyle
however now I'm faced with a challenging
decision I'm currently a teacher and
while I thoroughly enjoy aspects of my
job my real passion and it has been for
over 10 years is writing a young adult
fiction while I'm only 28 years old I
feel like my window to pursue my dream
of being a published author is
diminishing I don't know whether to
continue teaching for the next two years
to pay off my mortgage and save up some
emergency money or to take the leap of
faith and pursue writing I want to do
the responsible thing so so ji I mean it
is clear that Matt's life is over a 28
it's way too yeah that's that's one unit
yeah that's that's when you hang up the
gloves no I I do want to congratulate
you it sounds like you've made some
really significant yeah no provements
student loan debt is gone at 28 oh my
god I don't even think I even started
thinking about it until I was 28 I just
like to lock in the lowest interest rate
and just let it sit there that's good
and he's part of I think the 34 percent
of Americans who can actually fit a car
in their garage he's ahead of the curve
I think yeah isn't that it's amazing
that like we well the things we think we
need right and so we we fill our life
with a bunch of things that are the
they're the object of our desire but as
soon as we get them they become the
object of our discontent yes then you
have to maintain those things right
right and and yeah there's all these
other embedded costs you like there's a
price tag on the thing but then there's
like watering the thing and changing the
oil and the thing and and cleaning the
thing and storing the thing to drag try
owning a recording studio well we're in
one but we literally have a zoom h6 over
there you want to make Americana music
records if there's a lot more equipment
involved indeed let's push that cuz so
it's Matt was it Matt it is Matt yeah
matt is 28 years old it sounds like he
has a lot of his ducks in a row sounds
like he's he's in a great relationship
and he's like trimmed trimmed the fat in
a great way
but Matt life is short if you have a
passion follow it sir you know that
responsible responsible - what yeah you
know it's not like most other people's
expectations is I think quite often
words that might be part of it but it's
not like there's you know 600 hungry
kids that he has to feed and I would say
it sounds like he's in a great
supportive relationship and I I would
have to guess that his wife is going to
be very supportive of him going after
the thing that he he has some deep
propensity towards following yeah I
think things I would talk about here
Warren is I think quite often we
presuppose that it is by an area like I
either I need to run into my boss's
office today and say screw you I quit
right and then like now I'm a writer all
of a sudden but I think there's there's
a lot of overlap I wrote for most of my
20s while I was still in the corporate
world
um and and I got better at the craft by
writing now I didn't have any time yeah
you talked about carving out in time
earlier and so I was working 80 hours a
week
I managed 150 retail stores and so I
didn't have any time at all so what I
did I woke up an hour earlier I set my
alarm for 444 a.m. every morning and I
wrote for one hour and I got so much
better at writing right it's gonna make
the time and you see how much time is
available and just carve out that for
this thing that you really care about I
don't know if you experienced it with
music
but writing seems to be one of the
crafts where people think they're just
gonna get better via osmosis like I do
it you gotta do it every day right you
don't know any carpenters who are like
aspiring carpenters they're like just
that they're gonna become a carpenter
right and they actually have to build
things in order to be a carpenter but
with Wright I teach a writing class and
with the students quite often I found
that a lot of people who aspire to write
don't actually write because it's it's
scary and it's going to be bad at first
and and even worse it's going to seem
good at times but unbeknownst to you
it's actually going to be bad still and
that's okay
you have to produce the sediment in
order for you in order for you to be
able to pan for the gold yeah sure and
so the other thing I think about here is
also transference there's this this
thing I think about so I wrote fiction
throughout most of my 20s and got better
at writing as a result I write very
little fiction now but that skill
transferred over to several things it
transferred over to writing nonfiction
blog posts or even tweets you know we do
a really great job with our Twitter
account because it's it's always just
well curated sort of minimal Maxim's and
in aphorisms and things like that
because I've gotten better at writing
writing books is a way that I
transferred that skill set but also
writing talks you know he mentioned are
our TED talk well
I wrote the TED talk and so that skill
set does transfer other places you just
because you're passionate about one
thing doesn't mean that passion can't
transfer to other areas as well yeah I
don't see the I don't see the conflict
you know I know that teaching is an
extremely demanding you know occupation
but there's I have to guess there's time
there's time left over where he can he
can explore explore this writing
obsession and by the way you can become
a teacher again later if you decide you
want to I do but I did it right right up
write a book and see where it goes
right right for books you know write
write a book they're the first one out
write it again right yeah Seth Godin
talks about the question isn't should
you write a book the the answer to that
is is yes you should write a book the
question is your will someone actually
end up reading and you know we thought
remains to be seen yeah yeah it
certainly they won't read it if you
don't write it but getting back to the
you know the joy of creating versus the
joy of having created the thing that
compels us to create is the act of
creation it's not it's not to have like
a bunch of books on your wall or records
on your wall to see if you actually like
it you know yeah right and you can do
that right now while you're teaching I
think you can head down this path and by
the way if you're in debt you still have
some debt yeah it might be irresponsible
for you to run away right now and quit
your job but you can have a plan
together so that a year from now or two
years from now you check out Dave
Ramsey's Total Money Makeover you can
figure out how to be a hundred percent
debt-free have an emergency fund saved
up and work on your exit plan at the
same time you're in a safe position
right now unfortunately you're an also
in a comfortable position and I find
that people rarely create things that
are meaningful when everything is at the
utmost comfort and that is true yeah
that is true
well man I'm gonna send you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've ever written
still it's sort of the story of Ryan and
I walking away from the corporate world
so we could be more creative now the
book has a soundtrack too
and Jay Nash is actually in in the book
there I think it's a big break the fifth
chapter there's a song called Wayfarer
because I'm meeting with someone so
every chapter has basically one song
there's 12 chapters so it has a weird
sort of soundtrack to it that we never
released obviously because I don't own
the rights in of the music but I wanted
to expose people in our audience to some
music that was really profound to me and
so mad I hope you enjoy that copy of
everything that remains will send you
the audiobook or if you want the book
book or the e-book we'll send that to
you as well well it's time for our
lightning round Jay this will be answer
questions from social media okay and
we're at the minimalists on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram
Jay Nash can be found on twitter @ JN or
nash that's right and on instagram @ i
am jay Nash good good and yeah you can
tweet at him
Instagram at him I do it and find him
there so we've got some questions for
social media now we typically answer
these questions with short shareable
less than 140 character response okay
you don't have to worry about that
though what podcast Shawn does heat
wheezes something out that sounds pithy
and he puts it in the show notes so
people can copy and share our put the
answers on social media if they'd like
and now you can find all of our our
quotes in one place minimal Maxim's calm
our first lightning round question is
from Amanda what's the best time of day
to be at your best creatively it's
difficult to find time outside of all
the noise let me give you my pithy
answer and then you tell me what you
think the best time of day to create is
today I think that I'll be considered
stand-up now I think the for me it's
always morning that's when I feel most
creative but I know some people they're
like midday I take a lunch break and
it's ideal for me and so I think it's
perspectival in a way like what what
works for you may not work for me how
about you Jay what depends on your
lifestyle - you know there's a long
stretch where it was the middle of the
night before I went to bed after I'd
sort of absorbed a day's worth of
experience and
you know the entire city of Los Angeles
is asleep and you have this you know
orange hazy glow overhead you know
nowadays for me it's where there's space
where I can find space where I can find
an empty house where there's no noise so
you know you there obviously you need to
sort of plan that time around when
you're going to have the energy in the
space to do it but I think every person
is different morning is great you know
if if you're if you're if you have good
energy in the morning you've had a good
a good nutritious breakfast and a cup of
good strong bracing coffee the day is
your oyster I find that really early
works well for me like I get up without
an alarm quite often it like for I am
3:30 a.m. I'm not recommending that to
anyone but it's a christ that's when a
3:30 like okay no but yeah yeah settle
down but it's sort of the same thing you
were talking about like Los Angeles is
still asleep there's no distractions for
me and so I I used to have to have all
these rules in order to create and I
never created as a result like I would
have 15 things I need to be done I need
to fold the laundry I need to have my
cup of coffee I need to make sure I've
had that's not OCD there's nothing
obsessive or compulsive either of the
things you just said my one rule now is
I have to wake up basically and that's
it because I didn't figure out how to
write in my sleep yet but but I think
that that ultimately having as few rules
as possible does to set you up for
success yeah knowing that you can create
something anytime right you know and
that and that is that is the truth you
know whether it's a song or it's a
social media poster it's a book a line
from a book it can happen at any time
you just keep your heart in your mind
open and there's a good chance that the
good things will will sort of pass
through yeah yeah
our next question is from Suren how do
we discipline our thoughts from the
nonstop ideas we keep getting how do we
choose which one to focus on well my my
pithy answer is an idea isn't power
on an idea is power we get a lot of
ideas but if ideas aren't really worth
that much it's the action itself yeah
you might get a song idea but if you
never write the song then I have an idea
if you're exposed to an idea that did
sticks with you and resonates with you
that's a good indication that that's one
that you should act on if Sauron is
feeling as though he's overwhelmed by
all of the noise I would have to say you
know again take a minute take a beat
turn the turn the phone off
look at the sky take a walk in the woods
close your eyes take some deep breaths
you know quiet the noise take take a
moment just to ferment meditate and just
think just think about taking twenty
deep breaths and then see where you at
and then chances are there'll be one or
two thoughts that remain that are
important you know it's like it's like
minimizing your life with stuff it was
like does this thing have any value is
it bringing joy into my life or does it
not and if it doesn't you can let it go
and if it does hold on to it chase it
you know chase it down and see where it
takes you Minoo asks as a creative
person I really like the way this was
accidentally phrased here but as a
creative person how do you get the
inspiration now that that article there
the inspiration yeah and I think that's
quite often the problem don't you like
we're searching for the inspiration yeah
you know you don't necessarily know you
don't know there's no you know I've been
doing I've actually been making music
for my living for 21 years which is
absolutely absurd and I still don't
fully understand it except for the fact
that like you said you just got to sit
down and do it yeah you know you may see
you may be you may wake up one morning
like man nothing's here nothing's here
but if you sit down and just start
putting ideas musical and lyrical
otherwise into the world and you kind of
logged them it may not it's sort of like
the performance thing a lot of times I
don't even stand-up comedians or
musicians
on stage it's very hard to gauge what is
happening with the audience yeah you
know there are nights where you think
man I have never played better than I'm
playing tonight and it's lost on the
audience so you're having a night where
it feels like in your head that you're
really struggling and then afterwards
people like that was the seminal show
that was the greatest performance and
you there's a total disconnect it
doesn't make any sense the same I think
is true you know with creating with with
with writing whatever it is you can't
judge yourself as it's coming out you
just have to let it come out you know it
save the editorial that's good
save the editorial phase for later yeah
you know in my writing class I teach
four most powerful words a writer ever
told me it was sit in the chair because
it's not about the inspiration it's not
about the word count it's not about how
many songs am I going to write this week
it's about actually just just taking the
time to do it and as you said early on
that there may not be anything
productive today in fact some of my most
productive writing days are our negative
2000 word days where I've deleted stuff
from a priest I've chiseled out there
the sort of the statue from the the set
of men
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions here today what are some
specific examples for when limitations
improve creativity how do I know whether
I have too many hobbies we could talk
about that you collect guitars still how
can someone apply minimalism to music
and other creative pursuits what
creative advice would you give your
younger self and a bunch more surprise
questions good ones also twenty-five
ways to be more heavy we have another
couple hours yeah we got we've got some
time we got some questions and if you
want to hear all that you can listen to
this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast we
gives us the space we need to talk about
topics we don't typically discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it a
hundred percent advertisement free when
you subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you can find all the details and all
the good stuff over at the minimalists
comm slash support also it's probably
worth noting that we're capping our
patreon audience at 6,000 patreon
subscribers the reason we're doing that
is we want to keep it relatively private
it's a private podcast for a reason so
if you want to get in on that you
certainly can but only until we have
6000 patreon subscribers alright let's
listen to some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi Josh and Ryan
I just wanted to share an experience I
had with your listeners because I often
think about what to do and situations
with gift giving and gift receiving and
when my birthday rolled around this year
I really wanted to have a talk with some
of my friends about how I wanted to
celebrate and how I don't really want
physical gifts because a lot of the
times I don't use the things that they
give me and when we started talking
about it they actually to my surprise
agreed and they were actually talking
about how they really don't even like to
just aimlessly walk around the mall and
just trying to kind of find something
that they think I might like and we all
agreed that it was kind of a pointless
and aimless unintentional way to shop
for somebody and I was really surprised
at what they had to say about it and
that they actually agreed not to do
gifts this year so I just wanted to
encourage everybody to have those
discussions even though they're hard
because you never know what they might
say and they might actually be relieved
to hear that you don't want a gift and
they can save money that way and just
enjoy their time with you yeah I just
wanted to let everybody know that some
people will actually agree with you even
if they're not minimalist hi my name is
Clara Bay Hill I'm from Amherst
Massachusetts so I really enjoy your
podcast I am in the military I'm a
member of the Coast Guard and I'm really
liking seeing the connection between
mental and Muslim and being in the
military you know we have the same
uniform every day really just a basic
amount of stuff and just having that
freedom of everything you need just
keeping in what we call our sea bag
which is that green military like
backpack thank you and I really enjoy
your podcast alright y'all thanks again
to Jayne Ashe for joining us today
certainly one of my favorite musicians I
want to acknowledge him for creating
something meaningful something that
certainly resonates with me I want you
to check out his music just go to Jay
NASSCOM or you can find his side-project
as well we are the contenders com he has
a band with Josh day and they tour and
they produce some great music we are the
contenders calm and real quick four
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists I am a writing teacher and I
teach an online writing class it's
called how to write better and you can
find out details that how to write
better dot-org a quick synopsis we're
all writers now and I believe that a
rising tide lifts all boats so if you
want to improve your writing whether
it's writing business emails or tweets
or text messages or maybe you want to
start a blog or you want to write your
first book I've had everyone from high
school students to medical doctors take
this class and they have gotten value as
long as they're willing to put in the
work that is one caveat I have I do
require one hour of work a day over the
course of four weeks it's a four-week
class and if you have the time to put
forward into that I can guarantee you
that you will learn how to write better
you can check it out at how to write
better org and if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm you can comment
on this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
at the minimalists dot-com
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails each week for our added value
this week let's finish with one of my
favourite Jay Nash songs it's a song
called over you from his 2008 album the
things you think you need and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus